2/3 of people in
the United States
know that we only
use 10% of our brain.
And by "know," I mean are
crazy, horribly, mistaken.
Anthony here for D News, and
according to a brain health
survey from the Michael J. Fox
Foundation, 65% of Americans
think that we only use 10% of
our brains on a daily basis.
It's definitely something
I've heard in my life over,
over and over again.
Wait a minute.
Were those people insulting me?
Here's the deal.
That is false.
It is crazy false.
There's not a part of your
brain that you do not use.
There is no dormant part
with psychic abilities
or the potential to
instantly memorize
anything you see hidden
behind some cranial roadblock
up there.
The human brain is an
incredibly complex organ.
And all its little bits
are highly specialized,
some of them in ways that we are
just beginning to understand.
The myth probably started
through a misquote
of the findings of a
study guide in the 1890s
by William James
and Boris Sidis,
where they attempted to raise
a child prodigy in a way that
would actually accelerate
his intelligence.
After raising the
kid to an IQ of 250,
James said people
only meet a fraction
of their full mental potential.
He just meant we don't challenge
ourselves enough mentally.
It's also possible
that the myth came
from early neurological research
in the 19th or 20th century.
As scientists started digging
around in all those brains,
it seemed like there were bits
that didn't change anything
if they were damaged or removed.
And now, we know
that some areas just
have very subtle and
specialized functions,
stuff you might not be able
to tell is missing right away.
I mean, there's a
part of our brain
that is just dedicated to
making electrical sockets look
like faces.
We also know that the brain
can rearrange and reassign
functions to a
new part of itself
if an old one is damaged.
But it's easy to see
how early data could
have made it seem otherwise.
We've got way better brain
data now, thanks to stuff
like fMRIs and
PET scans that can
show what the whole brain
is up to at any time
down to these tiny
electrodes that
can monitor the activity
of a single cell.
And they all show
the same thing.
Your whole brain is always
worrying and humming
with activity.
Certain sections work harder
than others at certain times.
But except for people with
actual localized brain damage,
nothing is completely dark.
There are some other
things that point
to the myth being wrong too.
I mean, our brain uses 20%
of our body's total energy.
Why would it need so much
if it was mostly dormant?
Also, unused brain cells
actually degenerate.
And autopsies of human
brains don't ever
show large-scale
degeneration that
wasn't caused by
an actual disease.
So no, you are not a
pill or a technique
away from being a
psychically-powered warrior.
But the real unmangled
quote from William James
is still true.
Most of us don't meet
our mental potential.
So now that you know that you
can access all 100 billion
of those neurons of yours at any
given time, go out and do it.
I'm going to learn
French this afternoon.
I wonder which part
of the brain is
responsible for unhealthy
levels of optimism.
Hey, what do you want to
know about the human brain?
Let us know down below.
And we'll answer some of those
questions in future videos.
And subscribe for more D News.